les événements se précipitent si bien
que les chefs d'État ou de gouvernement
des 27 ont déjà eu besoin de se réunir
vendredi dernier à Prague ils ont
partagé le même diagnostic sur
l'utilisation de l'art énergétique par
la Russie qualifiée de missiles tirés
sur le continent européen par le
président du Conseil européen Charles
Michel ils ont aussi partagé une
ambition commune de faire baisser les
prix des ressources énergétiques qui ont
un impact considérable sur l'économie
européenne mais ils ont constaté aussi
leur division sur les moyens d'y
remédier alors qu'il y a urgence à
trouver des compromis pour alléger
concrètement le fardeau des citoyens et
entreprises de l'Union européenne sans
attendre l'Allemagne a déjà annoncé il y
a une dizaine de jours un plan de 200
milliards d'euros pour protéger son
économie contre la hausse des prix de
l'énergie une forme de bouclier
antimissiles nationales et non européen
le président Macron s'est engagé à
convaincre les autres Européens et donc
à surmonter certaines des resticicences
allemandes sur un mécanisme de
plafonnement commun des prix du gaz
servant à produire de l'électricité tout
en prévoyant des mécanismes de
financement solidaires européens
préservant l'unité du marché unique ce
travail de conviction a-t-il déjà
commencé à produire ses fruits madame la
ministre c'est une question j'ajoute à
cela que nous n'avons pas en Europe à
pallier aux erreurs stratégiques
énergétiques des autres États membres
le plafonnement déprime ne risque-t-il
pas de priver l'Union
d'approvisionnement en gaz dans quelle
mesure peut-on espérer trouver une bonne
réponse commune à la crise énergétique
qui fera plus mieux
deuxième enjeu décisif du prochain
sommet l'Ukraine alors même que l'Union
vient de convenir d'un huitième train de
sanction nous vivons depuis hier une
escalade du conflit ne parvenant pas à
prendre l'avantage après 7 mois de
guerre et défiée par la destruction du
pont de Crimée la Russie procède
désormais à des bombardements aveugles
qui s'apparente à des crimes de guerre
et la Biélorussie menace encore ce matin
d'ouvrir un front en désignant la
Pologne la Lituanie et l'Ukraine quelle
mesure l'Union européenne peut-elle
prendre pour arrêter ce triste massacre
les nouvelles livraisons d'armes
envisagées sont-elles la seule réponse à
apporter
troisième sujet collatéral la communauté
politique européenne qui a vu le jour à
Prague jeudi dernier et réuni 17 États
en plus des 27 dont les trajectoires
diffèrent radicalement Norvège et
Ukraine Suisse Turquie Royaume-Uni
Serbie Azerbaïdjan que peut-on espérer
de cette nouvelle enceinte
le président Macron l'avait présenté
comme une communauté politique
c'est-à-dire une communauté de valeurs
certains des États participants diverses
clairement des valeurs de l'Union aussi
je m'interroge sur l'objet de cette
communauté qui aurait pu apparaître
comme une réponse à l'Organisation de
coopération de Shanghai récemment réuni
à l'initiative de Vladimir Poutine si
certains pays n'avaient pas participé à
ces deux rencontres pourriez-vous madame
la ministre nous éclairer sur la vision
française de l'avenir de la communauté
politique européenne après cette
première rencontre et je passe la parole
à notre rapporteur général du budget
Jean-François Husson
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
après les bouleversements induits par la
crise sanitaire apparue en 2020
2022 devait prolonger le retour à une
plus grande stabilité des finances
européennes amorcées un dernier mais la
guerre en Ukraine et la crise
énergétique en ont décidé autrement à
tel point que plusieurs sujets largement
débattus au cours des mois écoulés sont
désormais relégués au second plan et je
pense par exemple et notamment à la
question des ressources propres de
l'Union
je vais j'ai choisi de concentrer mon
intervention sur la question énergétique
ça ne devrait pas vous surprendre et
plus précisément sur les réponses que
les États et l'Union peuvent apporter en
termes de soutien financier pour
traverser cette crise conformément aux
champs de mal fonction alors il y a
moins d'une semaine la Commission
européenne a proposé aux États membres
de mettre en place un plafonnement
temporaire des prix du gaz
pouvez-vous nous dire nous en dire
peut-être davantage madame la ministre
sachant par ailleurs que la présidente
de la Commission a présenté cette
proposition je vais la citer comme une
première étape vers une réforme
structurelle du marché d'électricité
pour atténuer les effets de cette crise
sur les agents économiques les membres
de l'Union ont tous mis en place des
réponses nationales jusqu'à l'annonce
par l'Allemagne d'un plan de soutien de
200 milliards d'euros jusqu'à ce qu'ils
viennent donc faire prendre conscience
du risque de fragmentation du marché
intérieur une réponse coordonnée à la
dégradation des contes des entreprises
les plus concernées par l'augmentation
de les prix de l'énergie et les risques
de réduction d'activités qu'elle induit
vous paraît-elle à ce stade et en l'état
possible enfin l'ensemble des paiements
s'accorde sur l'objectif de renforcer
l'autonomie stratégique de l'Union en
diversifiant ces sources
d'approvisionnement en énergie 20
milliards d'euros supplémentaires vont
être consacrés au volley REpower u
inclus dans l'enveloppe financière du
fond pour la relance et la résilience en
vue d'aider les États membres à faire
face aux chocs créé par la crise la
hausse pardon vertigineuse des prix du
gaz et plus largement à la crise des
prix de l'énergie
pouvez-vous madame la ministre nous
donner davantage de précisions sur leur
répartition je vous remercie
madame la ministre nous voulait sur la
parole puis ensuite chaque chaque groupe
avec son représentant désigné prendre la
parole pour 5 minutes et puis on vous
laissera répondre
je vous en prie
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame la vice-président monsieur le
vice-président monsieur le rapporteur
général
mesdamesinatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs
c'est évidemment un grand honneur de me
retrouver devant vous et ce matin avant
de vous présenter comme une comme de
coutume
avant chaque Conseil européen les
principaux sujets qui vont y être
traités comme vous le savez c'est pour
moi le premier de ces exercices et il se
nourrit cette fois naturellement des
résultats du Conseil européen informel
de vendredi dernier ainsi que des leçons
que nous pouvons tirer de la première
réunion de la communauté politique
européenne comme vous les mentionnez
monsieur le président
la présidence check a souhaité réunir
les chefs d'État et de gouvernement deux
fois en octobre en raison des trois
chocs majeurs auxquels nous cherchons
ensemble les réponses les plus
appropriées il y a bien sûr la guerre en
Ukraine que vous avez mentionné la crise
énergétique et enfin la situation
économique puisque ces deux dernières
questions sont évidemment
intrinsèquement liés par ailleurs je
vais faire je vais prendre des
précautions puisque comme vous le savez
la situation évolue tous les jours et
donc ce que je vais partager avec vous
nos positions en amont du conseil mais à
vous me pardonnerez celles-ci sont
évidemment susceptibles d'évoluer à
l'aune des événements que vous
connaissez et des concertations qui sont
conduites entre en européen
je vais commencer par l'agression russe
à l'encontre de l'Ukraine qui sera
évidemment au coeur des échanges du
Conseil européen ainsi que la question
de la poursuite de notre soutien à
l'Ukraine
et le président de la République l'a
indiqué hier suite à son échange avec le
président zéninski notre soutien à
l'Ukraine et notre détermination à
l'aider à défendre sa souveraineté et
son intégrité territoriale sont
inchangés donc nous allons poursuivre et
intensifier le soutien politique
humanitaire économique et militaire
déjà à la fin du mois de septembre
l'Union européenne avait répondu
immédiatement au simulacre de référendum
qui se sont tenus dans les territoires
occupés en allant plus loin en matière
de sanction maintenant hier avec les
bombardements de plusieurs villes
ukrainiennes par la Russie c'est une
escalade et même c'est un changement de
nature de conflit puisque ces frappes
vissent des infrastructures civiles
elles sont donc une volonté délibérée de
la Russie de frapper la population
ukrainienne et comme l'a dit la ministre
Colonna hier ces actes sont constitutifs
de crimes de guerre et la Russie devra
rendre compte
nous dans ce contexte évidemment l'Union
européenne va maintenir sa pression sur
le régime russe pour la faiblir et
l'affaiblir durablement
et cette pression passe par des
sanctions elle a un objectif clair c'est
dysphyxier les corps de guerre russes
donc les nouveaux paquets de sanctions
qui vient d'être adopté à 27 contient
plusieurs éléments qui vont resserrer
les taux sur le régime russe d'abord il
y a le mécanisme visant à plafonner le
prix d'achat du pétrole russe pour les
pays tiers qui va contribuer à réduire
les revenus énergétiques de la Russie
encore un peu plus tout en maintenant
une stabilité des marchés énergétiques
internationaux c'est important dans le
contexte comme vous le savez
mais ce n'est pas tout outre de
nouvelles mesures sectorielles qui sont
très ambitieuses sur l'acier ou sur les
produits chimiques outre la désignation
de 29 individus et cette entités ce
paquet prévoit également l'ajout d'un
critère qui va nous permettre de
sanctionner les individus et les entités
qui facilitent le contournement des
mesures on a donc un arsenal législatif
qui est vraiment très complet et qui va
avoir des résultats massifs et qui en a
déjà d'ailleurs sur l'économie russe
comme vous si toujours les chiffres de
croissance je vais vous en donner un
autre cette fois-ci c'est la production
automobile qui est en Russie a chuté de
70% depuis août 2021
et évidemment ces sanctions peuvent être
renforcées à tout moment contre les
responsables russes contre la
Biélorussie si elle s'engage davantage
en soutien de cette agression
ensuite en parallèle évidemment nous
poursuivons le soutien à l'Ukraine dans
les différentes composantes que je
mentionnais sur le plan militaire
d'abord au delà de l'aide que vous
connaissez nous soutenons la création
d'une mission européenne d'assistance
militaire afin de répondre aux besoins
de formation d'armures et nous espérons
un rapport à ce sujet au Conseil des
affaires étrangères du 17 octobre donc
la semaine prochaine
sur le plan financier la France soutient
également les efforts pour permettre à
décaissement rapide de la deuxième
tranche de LED macro-financière à
l'Ukraine et aussi entamer les
négociations sur la troisième tranche de
3 milliards ainsi que son déboursement
d'ici à la fin de l'année c'est
important c'est ce qui leur permet de
continuer à fonctionner
sur le plan politique
évidemment poursuivons notre soutien à
perspective européenne de l'Ukraine et
ça ça a été très matériel avec la tenue
du premier sommet de la communauté
politique européenne à Prague au niveau
des chefs d'État et de gouvernement
cette communauté politique européenne
dont la seconde réunion se tiendra en
Moldavie permettra de nouer des liens
forts entre les pays du continent
européen candidats ou non candidats et
d'avancer sur des coopérations concrètes
puisque vous le savez le président
nacité 7 à la fin de cette journée là
en fait sur le plan humanitaire la
Commission a annoncé hier la poursuite
de la facilité temporaire qui permet au
réfugiés ukrainien de vivre et
travailler dans les pays de l'Union
européenne jusqu'en 2024
et puis parce qu'il faut nous projetons
et projetons le soutien à l'Ukraine
au-delà de la guerre c'est le volet
reconstruction qui doit nous occuper dès
maintenant vous le savez il y a la
conférence de Berlin le 25 octobre qui
va immédiatement suivre le conseiller
européen et l'idée de cette conférence
et de progresser sur une approche qui
soit coordonnée des différents types
d'aides et en lien avec les différents
partenaires dont par exemple les
organisations internationales
enfin pour
poursuivre avec avec l'Ukraine le
conseiller européen pourrait également
examiner le sujet de l'insécurité
alimentaire mondiale qui est causé par
la guerre de la Russie contre l'Ukraine
comme vous savez l'Union européenne a
mis en place des corridors de solidarité
qui ont permis de faire sortir du crâne
plus de 10 millions de tonnes de
céréales et puis nous avons consenti une
aide directe très importante au pays
vulnérable avec l'inacité l'initiative
pardon farm qui est portée par le
Président de la République qui doit
maintenant être déployé européen en lien
avec l'Union africaine et dans l'idée de
favoriser une sécurité alimentaire
soutenable dans le temps
et puis le Conseil européen va revenir
sur la question de l'accueil des
réfugiés russes depuis la déclaration de
la mobilisation partielle en Russie le
21 septembre si plusieurs centaines de
milliers de ressortissants russes qui
ont fui le pays et évidemment notamment
vers l'Union européenne
alors ça a été moins de la force de
l'opposition à l'invasion russe en
Ukraine bien sûr au sein de la
population russe
et ce qui concerne mais ça pose des
questions à ce qui concerne le
traitement des demandes de visa de ces
ressortissants russes comme du statut
qui pourrait leur être reconnu et nous
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que les
États européens suivent à nouveau une
approche commune comme ça a été les
comme ça a été le cas depuis le début du
conflit nous voulons vraiment préserver
cet esprit d'unité
évidemment on parlait de l'Ukraine
m'amène immédiatement à la crise
énergétique
et ce sujet sera abordé au Conseil
européen bien que comme vous le savez il
est déjà été beaucoup discuté vous
l'aurez appeliez tous les deux tout à
l'heure
alors d'abord le Conseil européen doit
endosser les grandes thématiques
abordées lors du Conseil énergique
extraordinaire qui s'était tenu le 30
septembre et des prêts lors des
précédentes réunions extraordinaires
aussi des ministres de l'énergie en
juillet et début septembre ces
thématiques sont la réduction de la
demande d'électricité la contribution
temporaire de solidarité des entreprises
fossiles la mobilisation des ressources
pour soutenir les ménages et les
entreprises
le règlement que les ministres de
l'énergie ont adopté enfin septembre va
permettre d'organiser la réduction de
notre consommation d'électricité il va
aussi faire contribuer les entreprises
du secteur de l'énergie à l'effort
collectif pour soutenir les ménages et
les entreprises dans cette période qui
est tout à fait
bien évidemment nos entreprises les
citoyens ne peuvent pas supporter tout
seul le coût de la crise actuelle et
c'est pour cela que les États membres
les soutiensront et ça c'est l'objectif
des mécanismes de captation de la rente
des producteurs d'électricité et de la
contribution temporaire de solidarité
sur les entreprises du secteur des
énergies fossiles
ces mesures elles ont été décidées en
européen et elles seront déclinées en
France dans le projet de loi de finances
est-ce que c'est suffisant non nous
devons aller plus loin et nous devons
prendre et ce sera l'objet du conseiller
européen de nouvelles décisions qui vont
permettre de réduire immédiatement la
facture énergétique de nos concitoyens
et de nos entreprises
pour cela il y a différentes options
mais l'objectif c'est de mettre en place
un plafonnement des prix du gaz que ce
soit sur le gaz importé de Russie
directement sur les marchés de gros
l'utilisation d'une plateforme d'achat
commun va être un levier pour mettre en
oeuvre ce plafonnement ou peut être un
levier j'aurais dû dire et puis nous
nous souhaitons aussi faire baisser le
prix de l'électricité en européen en
subventionnant le gaz qui est utilisé
pour produire l'électricité sur le
modèle de ce qui a été mis en place dans
la péninsule ibérique
vendredi dernier elle a président de la
commission a entendu ces messages elle a
apporté et il y a également un soutien
politique très fort de nombreux États
membres pour accélérer toutes ces
discussions
je crois que les Français comme les
citoyens comme les entreprises attendent
une réponse politique vraiment forte qui
soit coordonnées à la hauteur des enjeux
et donc nous allons continuer de mettre
un grand pression là dessus
et puis vous le savez la Russie poursuit
l'instrumentalisation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique de
l'Union puisqu'elle réduit
continuellement ses livraisons de gaz
en fait je crois qu'on essaie depuis un
moment elle n'est plus un partenaire et
un fournisseur fiable
et nous le savons aussi c'est les
relations énergétiques maintenant vont
être pour toujours bouleversées par ces
agissements du Kremlin au cours des
derniers mois donc nous allons soutenir
sans ambiguïté aucune les initiatives et
les propositions de la Commission pour
nous préparer non seulement au mieux à
l'hiver prochain mais également au-delà
et donc ça veut dire que la France
effectivement va continuer à soutenir
une réforme structurelle des marchés de
l'énergie pour parvenir un marché plus
cohérent et moins volatile la commission
c'est engagée à soumettre des
propositions d'ici à la fin de l'année
et comme je sais que ces questions
étaient au coeur de vos réunions du
mercredi 27 juillet avant la suspension
parlementaire aussi des derniers mois et
que vous venez à nouveau de l'émotionner
vous pouvez compter sur nous pour en
rediscuter et vous et vous rendre compte
des avancées
ensuite le Conseil européen va revenir
sur la situation économique puisque les
instituts les inquiétudes qui sur la
flexion évidemment pèse non seulement
sur nos perspectives de croissance mais
aussi créer des inquiétudes chez nos
concitoyens alors sur les perspectives
de croissance l'activité a continué de
progresser au deuxième trimestre 2022
dans la plus bonne part des grands pays
européens et comme vous savez la
croissance de la zone euro est restée
très solide à 0,6% pour le trimestre
ceci dit en même temps l'inflation a
atteint en septembre un nouveau record
historique dans la zone euro A+ 10%
après plus neuf 1% en août
alors la situation est un peu différente
en France grâce aux mesures nationales
que nous avons collectivement adopté
puisque l'inflation s'établit à 6,2%
. il y a également eu de nombreuses
mesures pour soutenir le pouvoir d'achat
mais nous croyons de nouvelles mesures
sont nécessaires elles sont en certaines
sont en cours de déploiement notamment
un nouveau chèque énergie d'ici la fin
de l'année pour les foyers les plus
modestes et puis le bouclier tarifaire
va être renouvelé en 2023
vous lui rappeliez tous nos partenaires
européens ont adopté des mesures
similaires
mais c'est bien normal tout le monde a
les mêmes soucis mais évidemment nous
devons veiller à ce que les mesures
nationales ne conduisent pas une finie à
une divergence économique de la zone
euro
et donc c'est très important que nous
agissions dans un cadre commun et c'est
vraiment le sens de la révision de
l'encadrement temporaire de crise pour
les aides d'État qui vise à soutenir les
économies à la suite de l'agression de
la Russie contre la rue Keren et que la
Commission vient de présenter
et puis et cela a été un peu abordé
vendredi dernier évidemment il ne faut
pas exclure la nécessité d'une nouvelle
action économique commune au niveau
européen puisque tous les États membres
ne disposent pas des mêmes marges de
manœuvre
et ça c'était le sens de la proposition
de la Commission qui est baptisée
ripower you et qui est actuellement
disposé en trilogue parce que la
Commission a annoncé c'est qu'elle
pourrait éventuellement faire de
nouvelles propositions pour que la part
de subventions de ce paquet financier
soit augmentée
enfin je crois que les différentes
crises que nous avons connues ces
dernières années a été moins de la
nécessité de réviser notre modèle de
gouvernance économique sur le long terme
et comme vous savez la Commission
européenne devrait présenter d'ici à la
fin du mois c'est recommandations pour
réformer le pack de stabilité et de
croissance
évidemment elles vont nourrir les débats
entre États membres et nous au conseil
et le président au Conseil européen
rappellera la position française qui est
que nous avons besoin d'un cadre commun
évidemment solide qui permettent
d'assurer la viabilité des finances
publiques mais aussi de soutenir la
croissance et de répondre aux besoins
d'investissement notamment pour
renforcer l'autonomie européenne
dans le même temps il y a une différence
notable avec la tradition jusqu'à
présent nous demandons que la mise en
oeuvre de ses règles tiennent compte des
spécificités de chaque pays afin de
permettre une plus grande appropriation
nationale des règles
à cette fin comment on ferait ça les
États membres pourraient s'engager dans
un dialogue actif avec la Commission et
le Conseil pour définir la trajectoire
budgétaire la plus appropriée
nationalement ça permettrait de
renforcer l'engagement de chaque État et
donc de rendre notre cadre commun plus
efficace
en matière de relations extérieures
enfin pour conclure nous aurons un
échange sur les relations entre l'Union
européenne et la Chine
comme vous le savez l'Union européenne a
défini son approche des relations avec
la Chine en 2019 autour du triptyque
partenariat coopération rivalité
systémique
ce triptyque reste pertinent mais
l'évolution du comportement de la Chine
ces deux dernières années des notes tout
de même un glissement graduel vers une
dimension de rivalité qui est plus
affirmée c'est pour cela que nous avons
besoin de se débat stratégique renouvelé
donc la réponse européenne doit être
adaptée et s'adaptée à ces changements
structurels que que l'on voit
dernièrement dans la relation Yoshin de
quoi je parle je parle de la position
chinoise sur la guerre en Ukraine de la
montée des tensions dans le détroit de
Taïwan
je crois aussi que l'Union européenne
doit accélérer ses efforts pour
rééquilibrer la relation économique
mettre en oeuvre davantage de
réciprocité
renforcer les outils de défense
commerciaux et poursuivre la
diversification de nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement pour limiter nos
vulnérabilités
ceci étant dit la Chine reste un
partenaire de coopération indispensable
sur certains enjeux globaux et
multilatéraux comme la lutte contre le
changement climatique nous ne l'avons
pas sans elle la protection de la
biodiversité ou encore la sécurité
alimentaire et la santé mondiale et donc
dans ces domaines nous allons devoir
poursuivre les coopérations
enfin je crois que c'est très important
nous allons maintenir une approche
européenne très ferme sur la défense des
valeurs et des droits de l'homme et la
publication de la proposition de
règlement de la Commission qui est
relatif à l'interdiction des produits
issus du travail forcé sur le marché de
l'Union et un développement très
significatif à cet égard
voilà pour pour finir le Conseil
européen il durera longtemps reviendra
sur la préparation de plusieurs grandes
échéances internationales d'abord la
préparation de la cop27 comme vous savez
elle est accueillie cette année par
l'Égypte du 6 au 18 novembre à
sharm-el-shake
le sujet c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
continue à augmenter au niveau mondial
et évidemment les tensions sur les
marchés énergétiques menacent
l'intégrité des engagements climatiques
internationaux et c'est pour cela que
nous souhaitons que le conseiller
environnement adopte le 24 octobre
prochain des conclusions qui vont porter
un mandat ambitieux de négociation de
l'Union européenne à la COP 27
il y aura également la en discussion au
Conseil la préparation du sommet entre
l'Union européenne et la zéane qui aura
lieu comme vous le savez en décembre la
Diane c'est cet espace stratégique qui
occupe une place centrale dans la région
adopacifique
et le sommeil va être une étape cruciale
pour convaincre les pays de laserienne
de prendre une position qui soit plus
affirmée de condamnation de l'agression
russe
ça va être aussi également l'occasion de
mettre en oeuvre la stratégie UE pour la
coopération dans l'adopacifique et puis
la stratégie Globo getaway sur la
connectivité et nous devons identifier
des projets phares y compris dans le
domaine des infrastructures de qualité
enfin lorsque nous allons discuter de ce
sujet il faudra également et ce sera la
position de la France rappeler la
question de la représentation de la
Birmanie qui ne devra en aucun cas être
présente à un niveau politique au sommet
et nous souhaitons que la position
européenne de non reconnaissance de la
jungle soit
voilà vous le voyez monsieur le
Président Mesdames messenatrices
Messieurs et sénateurs c'est un
programme chargé pour ce conseil
européen il témoigne de l'énergie de
l'Union européenne pour faire face
ensemble aux conséquences de l'agression
russe contre l'Ukraine je viens de
présenter les principaux enjeux dans les
grandes lignes mais je me réjouis que
cette audition et je vous remercie
d'être là aussitôt ce matin nous permet
d'entrer dans le détail des débats qui
vont avoir lieu la semaine prochaine
merci beaucoup
merci Madame la Ministre alors j'ai
oublié de le préciser en préambule mais
cette audition cette séquence est filmée
en direct sur le site du Sénat je vais
donc laisser maintenant la parole au
groupe alors on est dans les mêmes la
même configuration que si on était en
séance c'est-à-dire 5 minutes de prise
de parole par par groupe je vous
demanderai quand même de respecter votre
temps de parole pas une ou deux secondes
près mais en tout cas
soyez soyez attentif à ça puisque ça
fait 40 minutes globalement pour pour
les groupes si on veut laisser le temps
à Madame la Ministre de répondre et
ensuite les uns et les autres de vaquer
à nos occupations entre autres nos
réunions de groupe voilà ça nécessite
une certaine vigilance dans les temps de
prise de parole donc on va commencer par
le groupe LR et donc Cyril pelvat à la
parole pour 5 minutes merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre et mes
chers collègues vous l'avez rappelé le
prochain Conseil européen reviendra
naturellement sur la guerre du crâne les
succès militaires engrangé depuis un
mois par les forces ukrainiennes
renferce renverse le rapport de sur le
théâtre d'opération il démonte bien sûr
la compétence elle courage les armées
ukrainiennes mais aussi l'efficacité du
soutien que le rapporte les nations
occidentales en matière d'armement de
renseignements de formation et de
planification alors que l'Ukraine
connaît sur le terrain une dynamique
positive qui lui permettra espérons-le
de retrouver sa pleine souveraineté
notre appui ne doit pas ne doit pas
faiblir et vous nous avez rassuré sur ce
point à ce titre et alors que les
États-Unis ont encore intensifié leur
aide militaire pouvez-vous nous préciser
si une nouvelle mobilisation de la
facilité européenne pour la paix est à
ce stade envisagée
d'autant que face au revers qui subit
Vladimir Poutine ne choisit pas pour
leur la voix de la désescalade mais
celle de la fuite en avant le chantage
nucléaire la mobilisation partielle et
les simulacres de référendum ainsi que
les annexions de terre ukrainiennes qui
sont sont suivies en sont la
manifestation en conséquence le Conseil
vient d'adopter un huitième paquet de
sanction vous l'avez rappelé il contient
notamment un plafonnement du prix du
pétrole russe transporté par les navires
européens vers les pays tiers des voix
se sont élevées je pense par exemple à
celle du PDG de Total Patrick pouyanais
pour dénoncer les effets constructifs de
la mesure dans un contexte de réduction
de la production que vient de confirmer
l'OPE et d'entrer en vigueur imminente
de l'embargo européen sur le pétrole
russe acheminé par voie maritime
pouvez-vous nous préciser quels sont les
anticipations du gouvernement et des
autorités européennes sur les effets de
cette nouvelle sanction
d'un point de vue strictement politique
cet accord a été obtenu difficilement
mais l'essentiel était néanmoins qu'il
soit obtenu car il est primordial que
l'Europe présente un front uni à
l'approche d'un hiver qui sera
nécessairement compliqué à gérer au
niveau énergétique donc économique et
sociale et donc politique le gros temps
est probablement encore devant nous il
faut donc l'aborder en série mais cette
exigence d'unité pour faire face aux
enjeux immédiats ne doit pas nous
empêcher de regarder avec lucidité ceux
du long terme l'Europe est une crise de
sécurité énergétique dans le sens où
l'offre risque de s'avérer insuffisante
pour couvrir la demande c'est tout le
sens des plans d'urgence et des plans de
sobriété que les États membres ont
établi ce coordination européenne
ton anciennement avec l'abandon des
énergies fossiles et l'électrification
de nos systèmes énergétiques la
compression de la demande en électricité
n'est pas tenable il faudra bien en
passer par un accroissement de l'offre
l'énergie nucléaire sera donc un quad
qu'on en pense incontournable elle a été
dans le passé avec eurotum l'un des
piliers de la construction européenne
elle est aujourd'hui largement absente
des réflexions sur la transition et la
sécurité à négative du continent et fait
l'objet d'un travail de sable constant
il est donc grand temps de regarder la
réalité en face et de réengager un débat
de fond sur l'ordre de sécurité
énergétique de l'Europe
toujours au chapitre énergétique le
Conseil adopter le 30 septembre des
mesures d'urgence misant notamment à
taxer les super profits des entreprises
du secteur des énergies fossiles et à
plafonner les prix de l'électricité des
producteurs dit un frein marginaux
sur ce dernier point le texte adopté
contient un article concernant une
potentiel répartition entre États
membres du produit du plafonnement si
j'ai bien compris ce dispositif il
prévoit que lorsque les importations
nettes d'électricité d'un État membre
qui était en 2021
= ou supérieur à sa production
intérieure un accord de partage de
recettes devra alors obligatoirement
être conclu au plus tard le 1er décembre
2022 entre cet état et son principal
pays fournisseur pourriez-vous nous
préciser si la France sera concernée par
l'application de ce mécanisme c'est
longtemps l'activer de manière
optionnelle et enfin nous en dire plus
sur les principes généraux qui régiront
l'exécution de ces contrats
pourriez-vous par ailleurs nous faire un
état des lieux de l'avancée des travaux
concernant la réforme du marché de
l'électricité enfin du moins la
compléter dossier sur lesquels les États
membres ont eu l'occasion d'exprimer de
profondes divergence les scénario d'un
découplage d'un des prix d'électricité
de ceux du gaz récemment avancé par
Ursula wanderlionne se confirme-t-il
pensez-vous que les États membres
réussiront rapidement à se mettre
d'accord au garde l'urgence de la
situation les nombreuses de nombreux
entreprises seront mises en grande
difficulté ces prochains mois faut d'une
réforme permettant de faire baisser le
prix du mégawattheure et ce même si le
bénéficient des aides de l'État et du
plafonnement des prix pratiqués par les
producteurs infras marginaux je pense
tout particulièrement aux stations de
ski dans tous les espoirs reposent sur
cette réforme qui sera le seul moyen
pour qu'elle puisse maintenir leur
activité sans être déficitaire je vous
remercie
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je voudrais commencer mon
intervention en marquant notre
solidarité avec le peuple ukrainien qui
fait face à l'agression russe et qui
depuis donc six mois vit des crimes de
guerre de plus en plus documenté et
depuis hier fait face à des attaques
terroristes massives
sont territoire défend il défendent les
ukrainien défendent leur droit à
l'existence sur leur propre territoire
mais aussi leurs droits
d'autodétermination vous l'avez dit nous
avons besoin d'être solidaire au maximum
avec eux
quelle question si quel aide
pouvons-nous leur apporter si les
infrastructures vitales en matière
d'électricité et d'eau sont détruites au
cours des prochaines semaines
comment renforcer notre aide pour mieux
la coordonner je pense en particulier à
la reconstruction que vous avez évoqué
comment mieux coordonner notre aide
humanitaire je pense en particulier à ce
aux personnes qui sont visées par les
attaques et aux soldats blessés
quand on parle d'énergie
finalement on a l'impression de revenir
aux sources de l'Union européenne et de
du CK comment avoir de l'énergie pas
cher
et de manière solidaire et la question
est de savoir si en 70 ans nous avons
progressé
finalement l'urgence c'est de se sauver
cet hiver et il est important de trouver
des solutions qui soient finalement en
convergence avec le cours moyen terme
c'est-à-dire tenir nos objectifs
climatiques de ce point de vue là
la France et l'Allemagne même si ce sont
les deux grosses économies de l'Union
européenne ne sont pas des exemples pour
les autres parce que
nous avons des difficultés intrinsèques
en matière de production électrique en
France parce que l'Allemagne a construit
sa politique énergétique sur la
dépendance à l'énergie russe à augasus
comment arriver à reconstruire une
solidarité alors que les autres pays de
l'Union européenne ne regardent comme
étant défaillant
comment faire pour que le décalage qui
va s'exprimer actuellement entre les
moyens nationaux et monsieur le
Président évoqué les moyens allemands
qui vont être mis en oeuvre pour faire
face à la crise comment ne pas comment
ne pas avoir que ça comme conséquence
c'est-à-dire régulation des marchés
européens
enfin comment peut-on imaginer
construire une dépendance demain de
l'Europe à l'Azerbaïdjan alors qu'on
voit les effets de la désherbelle de la
dépendance à la Russie enfin sur le plus
long terme ne serait-il pas temps de
s'interroger sur des infrastructures en
matière de transport d'hydrogène et de
capacité de coopération avec les pays du
Sud en manière d'hydrogène solaire
sur la question sur les questions
économiques la guerre en Ukraine qui
engendre une baisse de l'euro fait
baisser la place de l'économie
européenne dans l'économie mondiale les
taux d'intérêt sont en train de monter
et le modèle et le moteur de le modèle
allemand et le moteur économique de
l'Union européenne et pour le coup remis
en cause comment dans ces conditions
nous assurer que nous allons pas vers
une grande crise financière à partir du
moment où la remise les taux d'intérêts
qui sont de plus en plus élevés risque
de remettre en cause un certain nombre
d'actifs jusqu'à présent considéré comme
sûr je pense en particulier aux
questions immobilières et comment éviter
à la fois comment éviter les les une
prise bancaire à terme en matière de
relations extérieures je crois qu'il
faut vraiment avoir une vision sur les
pays les pays de du sud de la
Méditerranée qui sont aujourd'hui face à
une crise alimentaire et à une crise
inflation très importante il considère
que sont victimes d'une guerre qui n'est
pas la leur
comment arriver à reconstruire ces
solidarités avec eux alors qu'ils sont
particulièrement aujourd'hui
critique vis-à-vis de notre politique de
visa nous sommes en train de détruire
une relation historique avec les pays du
Sud de la Méditerranée par des
humiliations successives relatives à nos
politiques de visa comment reconstruire
cette polie comme on reconstruire cette
solidarité à un moment où c'est
réellement important enfin Madame la
Ministre sur la question de la
communauté politique européenne monsieur
le président l'a évoqué déficit
d'imaginer une comité politique avec
l'Azerbaïdjan là encore qu'est-ce que ça
signifie et si cette
l'ensemble européen qui nous permet de
remettre pour des questions pour parler
de sécurité et de la Grande-Bretagne
très bien mais quelle utilité derrière
s'il y a rien de commun entre les pays
qui sont dans cette communauté politique
enfin madame la ministre je dois évoquer
trois sujets que vous n'avez pas évoqué
quelle solidarité avec les combattantes
de la liberté en Iran le soutien aux
droits de l'homme et celle qui est
celles et ceux qui crient liberté en
Iran qui nous touche au cœur nous avons
débattu de cela au Sénat la semaine
dernière l'Union européenne doit être
solidaire de ces de ce combat pour la
liberté enfin les résultats des
élections en Italie nous montre combien
si nous ne sommes pas solidaires avec
les pays de première entrée la question
de la progression de la droite de
l'extrême droite en Europe et des
populismes et totalement posé quel
solidarité enfin en conclusion monsieur
le Président je vois que vous mais je
voudrais enfin en conclusion
vraiment la question de l'État de droit
de l'indépendance de la justice en
Pologne de la lutte contre la corruption
Hongrie doivent rester malgré les
priorités que vous avez évoqué aussi à
l'ordre du jour et en conclusion je
voudrais saluer la contribution de
l'Union européenne à la découverte par
Bruno Le Maire de ce que ce sont des
supers profits
merci Jean-Yves Pierlot pour le groupe
Union centriste
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues le 6
octobre dernier fut réunifié à Prague 44
chefs d'État et découvernement pour la
première réunion de la communauté
politique européenne nouveau forum de
coopération à l'échelle européenne
filet de cette instance avait au départ
nous réintent certains sceptifisme de la
part de nos partenaires européens tous
les états invités ont répondu présent à
ce titre nous pouvons dire que se sommet
est une réussite cependant quelques
doutes persistent quant à la viabellie
et la viabilité de ce format la taille
de cette femme rhum risque de constituer
le premier obstacle pour la prise de
décision commune sans parler des
diversités politiques et culturelles des
pays qui la composent par exemple
Turquie et Grèce côte à côte quel fera
la composition finale de la communauté
comment s'établiront ces relations avec
l'Union européenne la manière dont elle
devrait penser décision a-t-elle été cet
organe fera t-il doté d'un budget propre
voici un certain nombre de questions
qu'on est en droit de se poser
aujourd'hui
lors du conseiller européen de fin
octobre sera évoqué la situation de
l'Ukraine ça déjà été largement évoqué
je crois qu'effectivement aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui même plus qu'avant-hier nous
devons être particulièrement inquiet et
cette question sur l'Ukraine me pose la
question de la défense européenne on se
rend compte aujourd'hui que la
contribution européenne en matière
d'armement et dérisoire par rapport aux
États-Unis et qu'il y a cette prise de
conscience mais qu'il devient sans doute
urgent de créer une véritable
coopération de défense européenne avec
des moyens financiers à la hauteur des
enjeux et on voit bien que même si
l'armée une partie de l'équipement russe
va se trouver détruit ils auront
capacité à reconstituer tout cela sans
doute assez rapidement dans les trois
années habillées à venir et quel sera la
position de l'Europe en matière de
défense européenne
de la guerre en Ukraine les problèmes de
la crise énergétique depuis le choc
pétrolier de 1970 c'est la plus grave
crise d'énergétique le gouvernement
comme un certain nombre de pays
européens dont l'Allemagne ont engagé
différentes mesures avec des moyens
financiers pour l'Allemagne très
important
et Emmanuel Macron a appelé les élus à
la patience et à ne pas signer de
contrat d'énergie aujourd'hui estimant
qui ne ferait plus judicieux d'attendre
l'issue des discussions de Bruxelles qui
auront lieu au prochain Conseil européen
nous avons appris dans la presse qu'un
accord de bouclier tarifaire faisait son
chemin avec
l'accord de l'Allemagne aurons-nous
bientôt un accord et une décision
européenne sur le bouclier tarifaire des
énergies enfin dernier point mais qu'il
a aussi été évoqué le cas de l'Iran je
crois que la Communauté européenne doit
aux côtés de la France
montrer les dents et avoir des
représailles plus précises même si on
sent aujourd'hui un petit faiblissement
ou un début de concertation mais les
droits de l'homme les droits de la femme
en particulier doivent marquer les
valeurs de l'Europe unie et ce que ce
point sera évoqué lors du Conseil
européen du vin et 21 octobre voilà
monsieur le Président j'ai essayé de
faire vite merci en évitant de répéter
ce qui a déjà été dit c'est parfait
André gatolin pour le groupe RDPI oui
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre les chers collègues quand je
regarde des points affichés à l'ordre du
jour du prochain conseil guerre en
Ukraine stratégie énergétique relation
avec la Chine je ne peux m'empêcher de
penser que l'Europe est aujourd'hui
peut-être en train de changer de
paradigme jusqu'à peu en effet les
thèmes abordés lors des conseils
renvoyait de manière quasi obsession à
la construction du marché unique et à
ses politiques sectorielles dérivés les
questions de nature géopolitique quand
elles étaient à l'ordre du jour
apparaissaient généralement en fin de
menu et ne faisait l'objet que d'un
rapide tour de table pour constater nos
divergences en parler c'était comme acté
que notre continent n'était plus depuis
des décennies les pissantes du monde
alors oui la guerre en Ukraine reballe
les cartes d'une Europe presque
entièrement dédié à la production de
normes de standards de directives de
réglement très technique visant à mettre
en oeuvre les fameuses Cats liberté
supposées par ruissellement à coucher
d'une Europe toujours plus étroite dans
un discours assez prémunitoires de
janvier 1989 devant le Parlement
européen Jacques dollar prévenait on ne
tombe pas amoureux d'un grand marché
mais durant les années qui suivirent la
fin de la guerre froide nous avons na
vous lui croire à la fin de l'histoire à
l'émergence d'un monde sans ennemi à la
transition démocratique universelle
grâce à l'ouverture des marchés et au
développement des échanges commerciaux
l'effondrement de l'URSS a certes ouvert
la voie à deux grandes vagues
d'élargissement celle de 1995 avec
l'entrée de 3 pays Finlande Suède et
Autriche jusqu'à lors contraint à la
neutralité puis celle de 2004-2017 qui a
ouvert les portes au pays libérés du
jour soviétique mais dans notre fleurie
naïve de l'époque nous ne savons émis
les attendus géopolitiques qui animaient
ces pays en quelque sorte nous avons
failli nous n'avons pas proposé de pacte
commun de défense européenne pire nous
avons massivement désarmé comme en
témoigne le long déclin de nos
investissements militaires résultat les
expéis de l'Est se sont empressés
d'adhérer à l'OTAN avant de rejoindre
l'Union européenne ne voyant en
celles-ci comme de libéralisation et de
rattrapage de leurs économies nous avons
persisté dans notre fascination en amour
et pour le consensus de Washington selon
lequel le marché accoucherait
mécaniquement de la démocratie et de la
paix mondiale et cela bien après que les
États-Unis eurent ces 10 dernières
années nous avons refusé de voir les
signes avant-coureurs de la dérive
autoritaire et belliqueuse du pouvoir
russe nous avons ignoré les alertes
venus de nos alliés voyons en leur
crainte une névrose obsessionnelle est
passéiste nous devons aujourd'hui à
l'est de l'Europe admettre que nous
avons admettre la terrible cécité dont
nous avons été à la fois les victimes et
les responsables dans les faits nous
avons privilégié l'impératif économique
à l'impératif de sécurité l'Allemagne
forte de sa puissance économique et
commerciale a été le moteur européen de
notre aveuglement collectif elle a
notamment été au cœur des choix
énergétique qui nous ont rendu dépendant
du gaz russe avec la construction de nos
stream 1 et North stream 2 contre la vie
et les intérêts des pays de l'est et du
nord-est de l'Europe à un an près un an
après la fin du long règne dans Gala
Merkel son bilan apparaît aujourd'hui
bien bien moins resplendissant qu'à
l'époque ni il ne faut pas toutefois et
il sera juste de l'oublier la lourde
responsabilité de son prédécesseur
monsieur Guérard Schröder ni le fait que
nous avons nous aussi français parfois
accepter des compromis qui apparaissent
aujourd'hui des plus discutables en mars
2016 nous nous sommes ici au Sénat
fermement opposé à la proposition de
décision du Parlement européen et du
Conseil au nom de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de l'Union
européenne en gaz naturel qui voulait
obliger les États membres à soumettre
excenté à la Commission pour évaluation
et suivi tous leurs projets d'accord un
gouvernement gouvernementaux ou
modification
existant avec des États non membres de
l'Union la liste de nos erreurs et de
nos errements stratégiques au nom d'une
sacro-sainte souveraineté nationale
masquant souvent une
internationalisation non contrôlée des
échanges serait ici fastidieuses et
énumérer au regard des défis infinis que
nous devons désormais affronter alors
oui il faut saluer ici le réveil
géopolitique même s'il est encore tardif
et embryonnaire de l'Union il faut aussi
saluer le changement de cas présent de
l'Allemagne il faut aussi saluer le fait
qu'en dépit des railleries préférées à
l'époque c'est notre pays qui en 2017 a
osé porter publiquement la question de
la souveraineté européenne mais point
d'auto célébration nous ne sommes encore
loin du milieu du guais et le réveil
géopolitique de l'Europe reste entouré
de nombreuses incertitudes il appellera
encore bien des efforts que nos états et
nos concitoyens n'accepteront que s'ils
ont conscience que sauver reconstruire
l'Ukraine c'est d'abord sauver notre
futur le futur futur de l'Europe je vous
remercie
merci André Joël guerriot pour le groupe
Les Indépendants républiques des
territoires merci président madame la
ministre alors qu'on sort d'une réunion
informelle du Conseil européen que c'est
tenu vendredi à Prague les dossiers à
l'ordre du jour donc du Conseil européen
des vins et 20 octobre reste inchangés à
la crise ukrainienne vient se greffer
une nouvelle crise accentuée par la
première vous l'avez rappelé c'est celle
de l'énergie nous ne connaissons pas
encore la profondeur de cette dernière
mais déjà nos territoires et citoyens
font face à une première vague de
conséquence
les réponses apportées par les Européens
au conflits Ukrainiens nous au nord et
je me rappelle de la première réunion
qui s'est tenue deux jours après le
conflit ici au Sénat et j'avais pu
constater à quel point il y avait une
unanimité parmi nous et tous les pays
qui est intervenaient de manière
spontanée aller dans la même direction
ce qui était pour nous tous un bel un
beau présage de solidarité européenne
mais cette guerre nous plonge également
en face à nous-mêmes et au lacune de
notre système énergétique vous avez et
vous avez évoqué à l'instant l'idée
d'une plateforme d'achat mais encore
faudra-t-il que nous mettions d'accord
quand à la chaîne d'approvisionnement ça
sera à mon sens un écueil pas facile à
régler la guerre en Ukraine exacerbe ce
qui était l'attent et que nous n'avions
donc pas réglé dans le passé le marché
intérieur européen d'énergie inachevé et
surtout à réorienter s'il est
dispositions que nous prenons
actuellement semblent aller dans le bon
sens une réflexion très profonde est
amenée ce qui ressort de la réunion de
Prague est intéressante à bien des
égards et d'abord sur le fait que les
accords restent difficiles à trouver ce
sommet était considéré comme une sorte
de préconseille européen les points
essentiels tels que le plafonnement du
prix du gaz ou encore des aides
financières ont été évoquées force de
constater qu'il reste du travail
effectué pour se mettre d'accord avant
le 20 octobre
en tant qu'observateur nous voyons
quelques lignes se dessiner avec une
Allemagne que l'on pourrait croire
s'éloigner de la solidarité qui incombe
à l'Europe
quand la France conduit l'Europe les
saints de l'Europe elle pensera et quand
l'Allemagne conduit le destin de
l'Europe on a l'impression qu'elle pense
plutôt à maligne Madame le Ministre cuit
du pomoteur franco-allemand dans cette
nouvelle crise les deux pays avaient
réussi à entraîné l'Europe avec
d'importants progrès et des textes
nécessaires lors de la pandémie covid-19
sommes-nous aujourd'hui s'éloignés quels
sont les derniers obstacles à un accord
comme je disais ces réponses devront
être accompagnées d'une réflexion plus
profonde la structure de notre système
est à revoir nous devons faire de cette
crise un point de départ vers les
transitions que nous nous sommes
nous-mêmes fixées je pense surtout aux
aides et prêts qui pourraient être
accordé il faut qu'il servent à réformer
notre système tout en préservant nos
acquis malgré de volontés de dépendance
et de souveraineté face au reste du
globe nous européen reste encore trop
exposés au tumulte du monde avec la
nécessité de renforcer nos solidarités
très concrètement nos citoyens souffrent
de la crise énergétique il en va de même
de nos collectivités quant aux
entreprises elles sont fortement
exposées à un risque d'une perte de
compétitivité un tel choc pourrait
malheureusement être accompagné d'une
désindustrialisation massive
si les usines européennes venaient à
fermer à cause du prix de l'énergie
émotion d'une inflation galopante
comment saurions-nous capables de
produire pour répondre à nos besoins
nous devons apporter et notre solidarité
économique sera à ce moment-là encore
plus affaibli si nous n'avons plus
d'engrais que les prix de l'exploitation
agricole s'envolent faute
d'approvisionnement comment allons-nous
répondre à la demande nous devrons aussi
là importer et notre souveraineté
alimentaire serait affaibli
c'est les coûts de fonctionnement
deviennent beaucoup trop importants
comment nos collectivités s'en
sortiront-elles enfin comme les peuples
comment les peuples européens passeront
cet hiver et hiver prochain sur ce
dernier point madame la ministre
avons-nous des objectifs de stockage
ainsi que des exigences sur les origines
de nos approvisionnements pour l'hiver
2023 2024 enfin je terminerai sur le
volet de la défense il faut le politique
extérieure européenne plus ambitieuse je
l'ai appelé de mes vœux et à plusieurs
reprises notamment lors de la coarition
de la boussole stratégique européenne
madame la ministre depuis presque huit
mois maintenant les lacunes de la
défense européenne apparaissent au grand
jour nos infrastructures ont été
touchées actes de sabotage ou non nous
devons prendre cela en compte nos
voisins russes menacent ouvertement le
ouvertement le monde d'une guerre
atomique en tant que puissance
européenne et surtout la seule puissance
européenne au sein de l'Union européenne
la France porte une lourde
responsabilité
Madame le Ministre n'est-il pas temps de
renforcer la cohérence de la réponse
européenne et des politiques étrangères
des États membres notamment au sein des
instances internationales en ayant une
Europe qui parle d'une seule voix merci
Madame ministre merci Joël
Jean-Pierre corbiset pour le groupe RDSE
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues je
commencerai tout d'abord par saluer la
récente intervention de la présidente de
la Commission européenne sur l'état de
l'Union le volontarisme la détermination
affichée par Madame Monsieur la VAN
derlayen en faveur d'une Europe
solidaire et ferme dans la défense de
ses valeurs et bien entendu le seul cap
à tenir les défis que nous font face
sont nombreux énergétiques climatiques
économique et aujourd'hui la guerre à
nos portes et remplissent l'agenda du
prochain Conseil européen en particulier
de la situation en Ukraine naturellement
mon groupe réaffirme son soutien total
aux ukrainien qui font preuve d'un
courage exemplaire et clairement
inébranlable nous sommes également
soucieux des jeunes russes en rupture
avec leur régime il serait souhaitable
d'avoir rapidement une position commune
sur le sort de ceux qui veulent gagner
l'Europe ce matin même en venant sur
Paris dans le TGV j'ai fait le voyage
avec le responsable de la sécurité d'un
grand groupe de cosmétiques français
mondialement connu qui me disait que
c'est directeurs des usines en Russie
étaient menacés par les autorités
militaires afin récupérer les fiches de
pointage et mieux enrôler immédiatement
les salariés au-delà du drame humain il
est clair que ce sont aussi la
démocratie l'esprit de liberté qui sont
visés c'est encore plus frappant la
lumière du dernier discours de Sergueï
Lavrov Halloween u puis de celui du
présent Poutine du 30 septembre dernier
dans ces conditions le maintien d'un
dialogue paraît compliqué quand les
dirigeants russes utilisent le conflit
ukrainien pour mieux pour fendre
l'Occident et ses valeurs si nous sommes
pas dupe quand à leur volonté de
camoufler leurs échecs militaires cette
violence verbale dessine pour le moment
une impasse diplomatique pour ne rien
arranger le bombardement hier de
plusieurs villes ukrainiennes dont le
centre de Kiev en ripos attaque du pont
de Crimée confirme que jusqu'au-boutisme
russe madame la ministre le président
Poutine ne semble pas avoir de ligne
rouge sans jeu de mots mais quelle est
la nôtre face à l'escalade qui se joue
sous nos yeux en attendant oui il faut
renforcer les sanctions contre la Russie
et continue à nous fournir une aide
militaire à l'Ukraine je suis leirai
toutefois que pour la France cela
signifie de nouveaux prélèvement à venir
sur son stock et même sur ses contrats
commerciaux comme cela a été décidé
concernant les canons prévus par le
Danemark je crois qu'il faut l'accepter
il faudra cependant aussi durant
l'examen du projet de loi de finance
avoir des garanties quand on maintient à
terme de nos capacités opérationnelles
et des objectifs fixés par la loi de
programmation militaire je reviens en
principal effet collatéral du conflit
qui va peser de plus en plus lourdement
sur nos concitoyens vous l'avez rappelé
madame la ministre la crise de l'énergie
mobilise fortement les institutions
européennes mon groupe s'inquiète des
difficultés à afficher à un fond uni
Barlin semble en faire cavalier seul
aujourd'hui la solidarité européenne et
une nouvelle fois mise à l'épreuve
doit-on regarder l'Allemagne mettre en
danger la zone euro par le bouclier
tarifaire elle vient de décider à
hauteur de 200 milliards d'euros afin de
lutter contre la flambée des prix mon
groupe est très ouvert à la question du
plafonnement du prix du gaz position que
le gouvernement soutient madame la
ministre Bénin avant la crise
ukrainienne le couplage du prix lexique
les gaz faisait des bas il reste à
déterminer le bon indice qui à la fois
le prix et l'approvisionnement une
équation difficile à trouver je le
concède au-delà de l'urgence nous
approuvons aussi le principe d'une vaste
réflexion sur une réforme structurelle
du marché d'électricité c'est aussi le
moment d'accélérer toutes les politiques
en faveur des énergies renouvelables ce
n'est pas faute de le dire je vois
d'ailleurs comme vous beaucoup de mes
collègues ici présents l'occasion d'y
revenir en détail dans notre débat de
demain au Sénat regardons en tout cas de
près ce que fait l'Espagne qui apparaît
à juste titre comme le bon élève nous ne
pourrons pas rapidement les bonnes
décisions dans un cadre commun la
question de l'énergie risque de
fragiliser une démocratie déjà éprouvés
par une succession de crise je vous
remercie
merci Jean-Pierre Jacques ferrique pour
le groupe écologiste
monsieur le Président d'un mamie chers
collègues avec les crises consécutives à
l'invasion russe ce Conseil européen
s'inscrit dans un contexte qui s'est
durci durci dans un sens contraire au
renforcement européen voire même aux
valeurs européennes le respect de l'État
de droit la protection des minorités et
la démocratie sont-ils encore des acquis
intangibles les replis nationalistes et
populisme monte face à la crise
énergétique les logiques nationales sont
de retour la régression menace la
construction européenne et la tenue des
objectifs écologiques pourtant limités
définies par le Green Deal monsieur le
rapporteur général la commission des
finances je viens d'évoquer à l'instant
le report au second plan de la mise en
place des ressources propres cela risque
fort à terme de contraindre l'Europe a
réduire la voilure de ces politiques
essentielles enfin parallèlement avec
l'inflation particulièrement la hausse
vertigineuse des coûts énergétiques
montrent les attentes les impatiences
des citoyens des citoyennes des gélules
locaux aussi impatience vis-à-vis des
politiques pour qu'ils apportent des
réponses à la hauteur face à ce nouveau
mur en quelque sorte après le mur de la
pandémie après celui de la reprise et de
la résilience après celui de la riposte
commune à la Russie face à ce nouveau
mur est-ce que nous allons dériver vers
on parlait de fragmentation tout à
l'heure vers une certaine dislocation
européenne allons-nous retomber dans les
Hermans du chacun pour soi et des
renoncements concernant l'énergie par
exemple les décisions que nous prenons
maintenant notamment sur les
infrastructures vont nous engager
longtemps je crois que la France comme
l'ensemble de ces députés européens à
l'exception évidemment du RN a raison de
s'opposer au projet de gazoduc mit cat
qui nous enfermerait dans la dépendance
au gaz pendant plusieurs décennies
encore ça prend ainsi nos objectifs de
décarbonation je crois qu'il faut
refuser une entorse majeure au principe
de non-financement des infrastructures
des énergies fossiles il renonçait
serait un précédent dans lequel se
précipiterai sans doute bien d'autres
États membres derrière l'Espagne et
l'Allemagne sur les prix de l'énergie à
la consommation il est également
urgent de les plafonner mais
intelligemment ce serait une erreur
d'opérer mécaniquement un simple
plafonnement avec une quantité de base
de 80% au coût plus accessible et les
20% restants bien plus cher on risque en
effet de pénaliser ainsi les ménages les
plus modestes votre collègue panier à
une hachée parlait de sobriétés subies
l'impératif de justice sociale doit être
bien pris en compte sur le front du
climat avec le paquet fit for fifty-five
les trilogues doivent permettre
d'étendre le marché carbone européen au
bâtiment et au transport le Parlement
propose de limiter cette extension aux
usages commerciaux c'est en effet
raisonnable évitons une nouvelle crise
façon gilet jaune la fiscalité
environnementale ne peut pas peser
injustement sur les messages sur les
ménages populaires qui n'ont le plus
souvent pas le choix il semblerait
là-dessus que le trilogue d'hier né
selon les échos pas vraiment porté ses
fruits il a même été qualifié
[Musique]
en attendant que deviennent les valeurs
européennes quand on Hongrie on veut
obliger les médecins à faire écouter le
battement du cœur du fœtus aux femmes
souhaitant avorter sur les droits
humains les droits des femmes
particulièrement lieu doit peser autant
qu'elle le peut sur le régime iranien
enfin pour conclure un sujet me paraît
relevé des régressions qui menacent
celui de la méthode de pêche dite saine
des mersal venus des Pays-Bas
essentiellement ce sont ces vastes
filets de pêche reliés à deux câbles
vibrants qui soulève les sédiments et
rabattre les poissons même les plus
petits raclantis mettant des zones
entières à blanc tuant la pêche mettant
en péril nos pécheurs artisanaux le
gouvernement français a balayé jeudi
dernier en trilogue l'amendement voté
par le Parlement européen qui donnait
l'opportunité d'interdire cette méthode
de pêche industrielle est-ce donc cette
industrialisation destructrice de la mer
que la France souhaite que reste-t-il de
la crédibilité du discours de qui se
positionnait fortement en faveur de la
protection des fonds marins
merci Jacques Pierre Laurent pour le
groupe CRCE
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
madame la ministre le format un peu
inhabituel de notre de notre échange
m'amène à être assez direct dans les
questions que je vais vous poser plutôt
que de faire une intervention comme on
en fait parfois dans l'hémicycle on me
concentrant sur la question énergétique
qui est probablement une des questions
qui va continuer à secouer très
profondément toutes nos sociétés dans
les mois et dans les années à venir et
donc ce sera des questions sur les
mesures qui sont actuellement en
discussion d'abord une remarque sur les
super profits enfin ce que nous on
appelle les super profits et ce que dans
le jargon européen on appelle
aujourd'hui donc la contribution
solidaire sur les entreprises qui
travaillent dans les les combustibles
fossiles d'abord une remarque c'est que
une définition est possible en tout cas
la Commission européenne s'emploie comme
définition donc on a souvent entendu
dans l'hémicycle ici qu'une définition
était impossible elle semble possible
même si je la trouve très restrictive
elle existe donc un débat sur cette
définition était et reste possible
la décision de la
qui était envisagée au Conseil européen
permet
ouvre la possibilité de taxer à 33%
les entreprises les entreprises
concernées donc ma question est assez
concrète
à quelles entreprises cette contribution
pourrait-elle s'impliquer en France
puisque j'imagine que les estimations de
la Commission européenne quittable sur
une recette de 25 milliards d'euros ne
sortent pas d'une d'un calcul qui est
d'une opération du Saint-Esprit mais sur
des évaluations précises donc sur une
liste d'entreprises concernées donc
quels sont les entreprises qui
pourraient être concernés en France par
cette taxe le gouvernement français le
visage-t-il d'utiliser cette possibilité
de taxation à 33% pour ces entreprises
et au total combien la France estime
qu'elle pourrait récupérer avec cette
contribution solidaire
sans ces éléments concrets évidemment il
est très difficile de juger pour nous de
la pertinence réelle de ce dispositif
deuxième série de questions qui concerne
la question énergétique de manière plus
globale et notamment la question de
du de la fixation des prix de gros
ma question elle est assez parce que
pour tout vous dire même en essayant de
suivre
attentivement toutes les décisions qui
sont prises on a parfois du mal à
comprendre
ces dispositifs et à comprendre leurs
effets réels sur un pays comme le nôtre
moi j'ai une question générale d'abord
c'est est-ce que la décorrélation des
prix du gaz et du marché de gros
l'électricité reste véritablement à
l'ordre du jour parce que ça fait des
mois qu'on que Bruno Le Maire à chaque
fois qu'on pose la question nous dit
mais bien sûr c'est ça qu'il faut faire
et bien sûr c'est vers ça qu'il faut
aller mais à force de regarder les
dispositifs qui se mettent en place qui
sont excusez-moi du jeu de mots un peu
des usines à gaz difficile la comprendre
on se demande si ces objectifs et bien
sur la table et au moins est-ce qu'il
continue d'être porté par la France dans
ces discussions
concernant les dispositifs qui sont
envisagés qui sont donc dans ces dans
l'hypothèse ou cette perspective
resterait sur la table des dispositifs
intermédiaires
d'où sort le chiffre de 180
euros du mégawatt-heure pourquoi ce
chiffre qui continue d'être extrêmement
élevé et très supérieur c'est pour ça
que je pose la question
au coût au coût de production en tout
cas concernant notre notre pays et qui
donc c'est un chiffre qui peut laisser
perdurer encore des systèmes de rente
indus
d'autant que la Commission européenne
prévoit qu'il puisse être dépassés que
les recettes des 10% de recettes
supplémentaires pour être ajoutés à ce à
ce prix fixé donc qu'en est-il
réellement qu'est-ce qu'on attend
précisément la France et quels sont les
objectifs que nous continuons à nous
fixer dans cette négociation enfin une
autre question concernant les prix du
gaz on parle du plafonnement du prix du
gaz au plan européen des corridors de
plafonnement
mais il y a une question très précise
est-ce que la fin des tarifs régulés du
gaz en juin 2023 est toujours sur la
table ça fait plusieurs fois qu'on pose
la question
et on a toujours pas la réponse à cette
question d'une manière générale sur
toutes ces questions moi je souhaiterais
que vous nous disiez avec précision ce
que porte la France
souvent on a le droit à des commentaires
sur l'état de la négociation européenne
mais sur quels objectifs précis se bat
la France dans toutes ses négociations
voilà je vous remercie Madame le
Ministre
merci Pierre donc Madame le Ministre à
vous de répondre au groupe et puis
ensuite nous aurons une petite séance
question-Réponses questions d'une minute
une minute 30 auquel vous pourrez
répondre
point par point merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci à mesdames et messieurs et
sénateurs je vais essayer de répondre à
toutes vos questions vous vous excuserez
mes redites éventuelles et
certaines précisions que je peux bien
sûr donner après
en bilatéral monsieur le sénateurs vous
m'avez parlé et posé des questions sur
la facilité européenne pour la paix ou
plutôt sur les efforts de défense
et nous sommes cherché et effectivement
nous sommes en train de de travailler
là-dessus comme vous le savez l'Union
européenne avait mobilisé de Virg 5
milliards d'euros pour organiser la
livraison d'armes à l'Ukraine via cette
facilité européenne de la paix nous
allons poursuivre ce soutien dans la
durée et le Haut représentant a
notamment appelé est-ce qu'elle soit
cette facilité soit augmentée d'une
sixième tranche de 500 millions ce qui
apporterait à 3 milliards et ça sera
au à l'ordre du jour du Conseil des
Affaires étrangères du 17 octobre
vous m'avez ensuite posé des questions
sur les effets des
nouvelles sanctions d'abord je voudrais
rappeler que les effets des sanctions
sont dans la durée l'objectif c'est
vraiment d'expicier la capacité de la
Russie à mener ses agressions et donc ce
que ce que l'on fait c'est d'une part
son industrie d'autre part les personnes
qui facilitent la guerre sont en
responsabilité de guerre que ce soit les
nouveaux généraux que ce soit
ceux qui ont facilité les simulacres de
référendum ceux qui font de la
propagande et donc tout cela à nouveau
visa affecter à la fois sur le plan
militaire mais aussi du narratif
la Russie
à l'inverse j'aimerais qu'on rappelle et
peut-être c'est l'occasion ici que
les effets sur l'énergie ce n'est pas
nos sanctions c'est la Russie qui fait
le yoyo si vous me permettez
l'expression avec l'approvisionnement
d'énergie de façon effectivement à faire
monter les prix et à déstabiliser nos
sociétés et la réponse est multiple et
j'aurais l'occasion
d'y revenir mais elle vise pour nous à
d'une part assurer l'approvisionnement
en faisant baisser la consommation en
assurant les stocks en diversifiant les
capacités d'approvisionnement en
accélérant sur le renouvelable mais
aussi à faire des boucliers états et
faire en interne et à agir en européen
et je reviendrai dessus puisque vous
êtes plusieurs à m'avoir posé cette
question pour faire baisser les prix
effectivement
juste
sur l'accord de solidarité à ce propos
dont vous m'avez parlé qui est dans le
règlement sur l'énergie je vous
reviendrai en bilatérale là dessus
puisque ce sont des négociations qui
sont je crois
toujours en cours
et enfin et je reviendrai à nouveau la
du dessus vous avez soulevé la question
du différentiel d'énergie mixe entre les
pays c'est vrai nous nous avons besoin
de peu de gaz par rapport à d'autres
pays qui en ont besoin de plus et ne
s'agit pas seulement de l'Allemagne mais
aussi de beaucoup de pays de l'est et du
sud-est de l'Europe ce qui effectivement
demande une grille énergétique qui soit
très opérationnelle sur le continent
pour qu'à court terme nous puissions
avoir ces mécanismes de solidarité un
moyen terme je crois que notre objectif
a tous il est commun c'est de sortir des
énergies fossiles ce qui nous assurera
notre sécurité énergétique
monsieur le sénateur
le compte vous m'avez également
interrogé sur le soutien que nous
apportions notamment en ce qui concerne
les humanitaires et le soutien à
l'Ukraine alors il prend plusieurs
formes j'ai mentionné dans mon discours
à effectivement l'accueil des réfugiés
qui est important et qui risque de
d'augmenter avec la nouvelle vague de
frappe que l'Ukraine vient de vient de
souffrir
je voudrais aussi rapporter tout ce que
fait le ministère des Affaires
étrangères avec son centre de crise et
de soutien ce que font aussi les
collectivités territoriales le secteur
privé pour acheminer un mille tonnes
d'humanitaire et de réhabilitation
d'urgence vous avez vu cette opération à
bateau sur l'Ukraine
nous nous sommes aussi concrètement
engagés pour répondre à l'urgence alors
que des infrastructures critiques ont
été frappées par les Russes nous
participons également à la
reconstruction du crene je l'ai
mentionné tout à l'heure mais aussi
d'anthification
des exactions et des crimes de guerre en
fait qui sont commis par la Russie en
Ukraine donc c'est à la fois un soutien
humain militaire comme je l'ai mentionné
tout à l'heure mais aussi
humanitaire
vous m'avez parlé de la France et de
l'Allemagne
et des différentes stratégies de
polysémique comme je venais de le
mentionner au sénateur pelva je crois à
nouveau notre objectif est commun à
moyen terme il est sorti des énergies
fossiles et à court terme il est
effectivement de s'assurer que
l'ensemble de l'Union européenne puisse
non seulement être approvisionnés mais
être approvisionné à des prix
raisonnables vous avez vu la fabrication
rapide de Méthanie les accord qui sont
passés à différents niveaux
je crois que on a on a tous et la
multiplication des conseils
extraordinaires de l'énergie le montre
absolument essayer de
s'assurer à la fois au niveau national
et au niveau européen et bien sûr il
faut faire les deux en parallèle
s'occuper de l'hiver et de l'hiver
prochain et prévoir le moins interne oui
nous demandons et nous l'avons demandé à
Bruno Le Maire l'avait d'ailleurs
rappelé depuis je crois après de neuf
mois maintenant une réforme du marché de
l'électricité à terme qui est différente
du découplage de court terme sur lequel
je reviendrai et nous demandons aussi
d'accélérer la sortie des hydrocarbures
et d'ailleurs l'Europe a un objet qui a
relever l'ambition de son objectif
puisque nous allons baisser nos
émissions de 55%, pas d'ici à 2030 par
rapport
à
1990 vous m'avez également interrogé à
ce sujet
sur l'hydrogène
et je vous remercie de cette question
comme vous le savez nous voulons que la
France soit le leader de l'hydrogène des
carbonée et pour ça nous devons investir
massivement
donc la France a mobilisé 7 milliards
d'euros entre 2020 et 2030 ce sont des
investissements qui sont soutenus par
l'Europe puisque le plan de relance
européen engie va en couvrir 2 milliards
et au niveau européen nous allons avoir
plus de 5 milliards qui seront mobilisés
par le projet important d'intérêt commun
plus d'intérêt européen comme un plus
communément connu sous le nom de Pierre
comme vous savez qui est sur l'hydrogène
juste pour mémoire la stratégie
nationale pour le développement
d'hydrogène des carboné a été annoncée
en septembre 2020 comme j'ai dit à s'il
s'agitait de milliards d'ici à 2030 et
ce qu'elle vit c'est le développement
des filières de l'électrolyse de la
mobilité lourde à l'hydrogène et
évidemment de contribuer ainsi à des
carboner l'industrie et les transports
et je pourrais vous donner plus de
détails si vous en voulez
vous avez également mentionné la
situation économique et la crise
économique et les crises
et les risques de crise financière avec
la remontée des taux je crois que juste
quelques points là dessus effectivement
les taux remontent mais les taux ont été
exceptionnellement bas depuis la crise
souveraine de la zone euro et donc en
fait là on ramène les taux à des niveaux
qui sont un peu plus en ligne avec la
moyenne historique vous avez mentionné
les risques immobiliers la France
bénéficie comme vous savez d'un système
où les taux sont fixes en général dans
l'immobilier ce qui est effectivement
est une protection par rapport au pays
où les taux sont variables lorsque un
ménage fait un emprunt immobilier vous
avez mentionné les banques comme vous
savez depuis la crise financière de 2008
la réglementation bancaire a été
considérablement renforcée et nos
banques sont beaucoup plus solides dans
l'Union européenne
vous m'avez ensuite interrogé sur la
communauté politique
européenne et je pense que c'est le
moment où il est probablement
utile pour moi de rappeler pour donner
un peu de sens concret je reviendrai sur
d'autres questions qui m'ont été posées
les 7 projets concrets aux pistes de
coopération concrètes sur lesquelles les
membres de la communauté politique
européenne vont plancher pour la
deuxième réunion qui aura lieu en
Moldavie dans 6 mois c'est cette projet
sont la protection de nos
infrastructures essentielles sont les
gazoducs les gaz les câbles les
satellites on a vu à quel point c'était
important une stratégie pour mieux
lutter contre la cybercriminalité la
propagande et la désinformation je crois
que ça aussi c'est enfin tout est
vraiment essentiel mais ça en
particulier une stratégie en intégrée en
matière énergétique nous devons limiter
nos dépendances et réduire les prix
également pour nos pays voisins parce
que on aura les mêmes soucis sociaux et
politiques cela se fait pas une
politique commune de la jeunesse et ça
pour le sentiment d'appartenance et
renforcer les coopérations entre nos
universités nos politiques éducatives
c'est renforcer une culture européenne
qui va dépasser les frontières
nationales
cinquièmement une politique intégrée en
matière de gestion des flux migratoires
d'accueil de lutte contre les réseaux de
passeurs qui sont des sujets d'intérêt
commun à beaucoup de des pays de la CPE
la mise en place d'un fond de
reconstruction pour l'Ukraine et puis
enfin des approches coordonnées sur les
grands sujets régionaux comme la mer
Noire la mer Baltique la mer du Nord ou
le Caucase
je crois que il y a un grand
enthousiasme des pays de la CPE
notamment on a vu beaucoup de
propositions pour tenir la prochaine
réunion si finalement la Moldavie qui le
fera ensuite l'Espagne et ensuite le
Royaume-Uni mais sa témoigne vraiment
d'un intérêt de travailler ensemble sur
ces sujets communs au-delà du politique
vous m'avez ensuite interroger sur
l'Iran et les manifestations
d'abord avec
témoins de dire à quel point vraiment le
cette répression est inhumaine et nous
touche avec toutes mes homologues
ministres des Affaires européennes ou
secrétaire d'État des affaires
européennes de l'Union européenne nous
avons signé un appel très très tôt au
début de cette de ces de ces violences
maintenant effectivement
dès 19 septembre la France a condamné à
ses violences et puis depuis 26 jours la
France continue d'être très active au
Conseil des droits de l'Homme à Genève
dans toutes les enceintes
internationales et nous le faisons dans
tous nos échanges bilatéraux et à tous
nos niveaux rappelons notamment que
l'Iran assassins à des principes
fondamentaux notamment les principes du
pacte relatif aux droits civil et
politique des Nations Unies et nous leur
demandons de évidemment les respecter
maintenant vous allez me dire ce n'est
pas suffisant et vous aurez raison au
niveau européen nous sommes en train de
finaliser des travaux pour sanctionner
les responsables de cette répression ça
va se traduire par des gels d'avois des
interdictions de voyager
et nous devrions avoir un accord en
début de semaine prochaine le 17 octobre
au Conseil des affaires étrangères
enfin vous vous êtes inquiété de l'État
de droit en Pologne et en Hongrie et là
aussi je voudrais vous dire que nous
nous continuons de de vrai et d'être
vraiment très très rigoureux sur cet
État de droit nous aurons au Conseil des
affaires générales très bientôt une
audition de la Pologne et de ce qu'elle
a entrepris pour assurer l'indépendance
de sa justice et ensuite nous avons
donné à la Hongrie un petit peu plus de
temps pour mettre en oeuvre les
engagements qu'elle a pris en ce qui
concerne l'état de droit et notamment
les mesures anticorruption à nouveau
elle s'est engagée à faire des choses
l'engagement ne suffit pas nous voulons
voir cela mis en oeuvre nationalement et
c'est pour ça que nous lui avons quand
je dis nous Europe donner jusqu'au mois
de novembre avant de regarder ce qu'il y
avait été fait
monsieur le sénateur l'eau vous avez
continué effectivement à m'interroger
sur la communauté politique européenne
et notamment sa taille je voudrais vous
rassurer merci nous n'avons pas
l'idée est pas de prendre des décisions
à 44 tout le temps l'idée c'est
effectivement de favoriser le dialogue
et les projets d'intérêt commun mais ça
peut être ambilatéral entre bilatérale
ou en pluriel latéral mais qu'ensemble
nous trouvions des chemins pour en créer
tous ces pays
à l'Union européenne et son état de
droit vous avez émotionné mais ça a été
très important de que cet espace puisse
aussi permettre un dialogue entre la
Turquie et la Grèce ou entre la Turquie
et Chypre de la même façon qu'il y a eu
un dialogue entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan qui comme vous le savez a
conduit à la signature d'un accord qui
permet l'envoi d'une mission européenne
pour observer et rapporter au Comité des
frontières ce qui est en train de va
passer entre l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan
en ce qui concerne le financement vous
avez raison s'il faut des projets
concrets nous aurons besoin de
financement tout n'est pas arrêté il y a
plusieurs choses qui sont à l'étude
d'abord il peut y avoir une contribution
des organisations internationales comme
c'est le cas dans le cadre du G7 ou du
G20 il peut effectivement pourra aussi
s'appuyer sur des programmes existants
pour ne pas dupliquer et pour ne pas
manquer des choses et vous pouvez penser
aux partenariats oriental par exemple ou
à d'autres projets qui existent
aujourd'hui
vous m'avez ensuite interrogé sur
l'Europe de la défense d'abord ça fait
longtemps que je ne l'ai pas rappelé
mais dans les avancées de la présidence
française de l'Union européenne et il y
a effectivement un cadre cohérent et
ambition d'action de l'Union européenne
avec la boussole stratégique qui comme
vous le savez est le premier livre blanc
européen en matière
de sécurité je crois que c'est très
important parce que ça va définir à la
fois ce que nous pouvons faire sur le
moyen terme mais aussi donner des
orientations qui effectivement vont
avoir des effets sur le court terme sur
le court terme l'Europe est parvenue à
mobiliser les 2,5 milliards d'euros que
nous voulons augmenter à 3 milliards
comme je disais pour la livraison
d'armes
à l'Ukraine mais avec cette boussole et
d'autres et les autres actions de
l'Union européenne nous allons aussi
nous allons aussi permettre d'encourager
les investissements de défense et de
rationaliser les différents engagements
qui sont pris séparément par les
nombreux États membres une question que
m'a également posé je crois monsieur
hussénateur gâteau lin et Monsieur
dessinateur guerriot
vraiment il y a une volonté de fournir
de l'aide et de la formation des
personnes de permettre des augmentations
de capacité des achats de munitions et
pour l'ensemble des pays de l'Union
européenne puisque
nous avons donné mais beaucoup de petits
pays ont aussi beaucoup donné à
l'Ukraine et donc l'idée c'est
effectivement de reconstituer des
capacités dans le court terme pour
continuer de soutenir à l'Ukraine mais
aussi de se permettre à moyen terme
d'être plus efficace plus rapide et
d'avoir des instruments différents et
enfin
et je crois que c'est le souci tout le
monde et je voudrais juste le rappeler
ce n'est pas de la concurrence à l'OTAN
c'est une articulation avec le temps et
quand on travaillera
[Musique]
quand nous travaillons tous les deux en
bon articulation les deux institutions
je crois que nous sommes beaucoup plus
forts et beaucoup plus efficace
monsieur listen acteur vous avez
mentionné l'énergie et notamment les
recommandations du président qui ont
très comme vous le savez parce que les
prix de marché immédiat sont plus élevés
que les prix futurs donc effectivement
il faut pas se caler sur les prix de
marché
immédiats et notre objectif c'est de
faire baisser les prix de l'énergie
je crois que
je crois que j'ai oublié une question
sur les visages j'y reviendrai je vous
prie de m'excuser
les trucs de faire baisser les prix de
l'énergie et c'est vraiment la direction
dans laquelle que prend le Conseil
européen et c'est moi juste vous
rappeler que la présidence check a dit
qu'elle réunirait autant de conseils
d'énergie extraordinaires que nécessaire
pour arriver à cet objectif j'espère que
nous aurons quelque chose pour le 20 21
octobre mais je suis confiante que nous
aurons quelque chose
de toute façon
dans ces mesures et comme je
lui disais tout à l'heure il y a à la
fois la réduction de la demande
je voudrais répéter que c'est important
parce que si on enlève de la pression
sur la demande avec une offre constante
pardonnée économiste qui est en moi mais
ça fait baisser les prix et notamment
les prix de marché puisque le signal est
et tout de suite perçu par par les
acteurs de marché donc ça c'est la
première chose baisser la consommation
et les stockages en tout ce qui concerne
la deuxième chose je vais le rappelais
tout à l'heure il y a effectivement les
mesures de solidarité pour s'assurer que
nous aurons tous ce qu'il faut cet hiver
et de diversification des
approvisionnements et aujourd'hui les
discussions qui sont à l'oeuvre elles
concernent effectivement directement la
baisse des prix donc il y a plusieurs
façons de faire ça et toutes ces façons
et ses options sont à l'étude d'où la
confusion que certains ont pu soulever
parfois on peut mettre des plafonds sur
les prix du gaz importer de Russie nous
l'avons fait sur le pétrole nous pouvons
le faire avec eux des corridors ça veut
dire que au lieu de mettre on va se
situer dans une ligne parce
qu'évidemment tout le monde n'a pas les
mêmes contrats européens nous pouvons
faire la même chose discuter la même
chose avec la Norvège mais aussi avec
d'autres fournisseurs tels que les
États-Unis dans la mesure où nous aurons
des prix qui seront suffisants pour
toujours attirer du gaz et notamment du
gaz naturel liquéfié en Europe puisque
la concurrence avec l'Asie comme vous le
savez va être forte donc ça c'est sur
les plafonds sur les prix du gaz importé
on peut également mettre des plafonds
sur les prix de gros dans l'Union
européenne à nouveau pour faire baisser
les prix du gaz évidemment ça ça va
demander des subventions puis il y a le
troisième sujet qui est celui qui est
connu sous le nom du mécanisme
ibérique dans lequel on baisse le prix
du gaz par rapport au prix de marché
grâce à une subvention d'État et donc le
prix de l'électricité fabriqué à partir
de ce gaz baisse naturellement ça
n'aurait pas beaucoup d'intérêt de le
faire en uniquement puisque nous
produisons très peu d'électricité à
partir de gaz comme vous le savez c'est
pour ça que nous portons une solution en
européen qui aurait l'avantage de faire
baisser les prix pour tous les Européens
et donc éventuellement aussi les prix de
l'électricité que nous importons
[Musique]